congratulations your second fashion ova
collection yes how is this one different
than the first well this one is
different than the first because we have
more color and we have more cutouts you
know what I'm saying it's more fun it's
more summer time yeah but it also have
that matrix look that I like you know
what I'm saying this one is very night
out like I think like my first
collection was like work fashion strict
winter bloody colors really dark color
like mustard olive red burgundy like
these colors are more like pastel colors
blacks of course like this is one of my
collections is this one your favorite
pieces yes this one of my favorite yes
it's very matrix it's very matrix and
it's sexy but it's so classy and clean
and I love it there's like a neon vibe
we're in the middle of like a vintage
vintage gas station there's a Lambo over
there yeah did you have any say in what
this would look like yes I saw I saw oh
crap there is so much bugs out here you
guys are everywhere like that's driving
me crazy
no no no wait no it's okay are you sure
these don't bite what is going on with a
set I mean there's like a neon vibe
there is a Lambo we're in the middle of
a vintage gas station yeah did you have
any say in this yeah it's like I wanted
like a neon jungle dented
desert vibes you know something
different like you know I know a lot of
people like expect like my collection to
be like all girls and a white screen and
just showing the outfits no I really
want like to look like a really high
fashion campaign because you know I'm
saying we're doing high fashion on an
affordable budget
I love how involved you are you're like
lady boss cardi B it's amazing yeah I
know there's books a year guys really in
the middle of the desert yeah we don't
have no service no Wi-Fi survival skills
and its finest your first collection
sold out within minutes yes is this one
gonna beat that record uh I think so you
want to know something like is that I
study what people wanted I always read
some of the pros and some of the console
my last collection even though is it did
well and it's still doing well so it's
just like okay I'm gonna be a little bit
more fun
no more summertime vibes and I think
people are gonna like this one for real
I feel like you're such a trendsetter at
this point like people come to your
fashion inspiration people come to you
for beauty inspiration when is the
beauty line coming soon very can you
give me a little cheese I don't know
something you want to do though
something that I wanted how do you deal
with balancing everything because your
career just gets bigger and bigger and
your star just grows and grows how are
you balancing everything and are you
experiencing that mom guilt a little bit
I do experience that mom guilt you know
like it's like you know like is that
right now my baby's with me oh she's
here yeah she's here but it like it
makes me so sad sometimes because it's
like oh my gosh oh that traveling I know
her sleeping schedule is getting a
little messed up and I know every single
time that she get on an airplane it's
all good until the landing she started
crying and I just be feeling so sad
because it's like I know the pain you
know where your ears pop mm-hmm I just
be so sad and like sometimes I wake up
in the morning and like she's in my bed
and I just want to cuddle with this
totally is it getting harder because she
is growing up and you're so busy and
balancing everything is it getting
harder for you it is getting harder
because she knows me like you know she
recognizes more now and it's just like
you could just tell that she like wants
me there like sometimes we should sing
we leave machine you little [ __ ] where
you going how is your life right now
really like influencing your next album
you're working on it right you want to
know what's so funny it's so crazy
because like when it comes to my my next
album and everything ours you think like
it's like well I can't really rap about
the struggle I can't really rap about
what I used to work work on because you
know I passed the next level so what am
I gonna talk about besides the glamour
but I feel like I've been in a lot of
drama I feel like people have thrown so
many things so many different crazy
obstacles and you
in my life that is I got a whole lot of
talk about this there are things that I
don't be saying that it's like you know
what every so much time that I say it
people eat me up but life for me they
say I complain to my church that you
know what I'm just gonna put it in my
music then yeah and also I don't think
you complain too much I think you keep
it so 100 so real all the time and
that's what people actually love about
you that's what resonates with people I
think yeah and you want to know what's
the funny thing a lot of people always
saw me like oh like why don't you be
like these artists these artists go
through this all the time and they don't
say nothing but the funny thing is that
the artists today they say that I'm not
like all the artists that come up to me
and say like I'm so happy that you're
art that you are like our voice like I
don't want me to say this so bad but I
can't and it's just like I gotta I gotta
stand up with people that that we you
know have the same shoes that we fill
the same shoes that we deal with the
same thing a lot of people will have
opinions of a life that they never lived
I cannot tell you about your job that I
don't know yeah I don't know yeah so you
can't tell me about my job about how I
should feel you don't live it sure are
we gonna hear culture on the upcoming
album you know how like dj khaled did
that Beyonce's done that um I don't know
I I don't know I just get too emotional
when it comes to that kids really yes
okay like I did a baby song they are
supposed to be on my first album and
it's this day when I hear it
you cried so maybe though maybe maybe
anyone that you want to collaborate with
I feel like a Beyonce collaboration of
course we don't want that you don't
wanna say you'd be down for it though
yeah you also gonna add actress to your
resume
Hustler's yeah how did that come about -
JLo call you did you call her well she
called me
well she first picked spoke to my theme
and I she really wanted me to do like
this I think like the second lead role
and due to the fact that I gotta work on
my album I got like a little smaller
role but it's just like even though my
schedule was busy like it's like
I had to be in this movie like this
movie is something that I currently it's
something that is like all the actress
in the in the movie I could sell them
right no no no this is how it goes
hmm because you know like the club there
the club that the movie is based on like
that's the type of clubs that I work not
the first type of clubs that I worked in
sure it's like yeah this was my life and
it's just like yeah yeah how is it
working with JLo in this capacity
filming well I haven't I haven't I
haven't been on set yet but I worked
with her before right and you know the
music video de niro and she's just so
caring like cuz I do you need this do
you need that like what do you need do
you want this yeah yeah are we gonna get
another collaboration for this movie you
and JLo oh I don't know maybe so you
know when like you know if sometimes
artists when it's like when things are
done is they hey what are you doing yeah
let's go to the studio you never know
what can you say about your character
what can you tease you'll get all your
get all dean 800 then I mean that was a
good one has your career gets bigger and
bigger how are you feeling about stardom
is it everything that you thought it was
gonna be harder better it's definitely
harder like the more money the more
problems the more people then that
things they know you and the opinions it
just gets harder people don't understand
some people don't understand the the
struggle some people don't understand
the work that I put in so they would
just always try to think that it came
easy for me and it's just like you know
it's something that I never thought it
would be like I totally understand the
meltdowns that these artists be having
why they'd be shaving their heads why
they go to what they go to because this
is crazy
yeah but you want to know something is
like I'm a target out I'm already famous
I got no choice but to keep it going
I know you feel for Britney though then
yes what she said I went through yeah
yeah it's it's a hard life that you guys
it's a hard life absolutely I will say
though people really want you to run for
political office would you ever do that
no because I feel like that's a big
responsibility you know what I'm saying
like it's just like it's not sometimes
like I feel like if I want to quit my
job today I could quit it like I realize
oh I don't care like that's it whatever
I'm I'm studying up for me and my
daughter yeah but it's like when you are
when you're like a political person this
is like you cannot let millions of
people down there voted for you they're
rooting for you
to make their lives better so that's
just not my thing but you would never
let millions of people down I feel like
you are a hard worker you show up but
it's not even about showing up you know
what I'm saying
I feel like I would be a democratic you
know I'm saying that the house is full
of Republicans right now it's just like
so I don't want to promise somebody
something and then it won't happen
because people are not gonna vote for
what I want or like certain things won't
happen like for example I want free
health care and I feel like college
education should be free that's how I
feel that's what I want I can promise
that because I don't know if sure there
were a lot of sad before but it must be
nice knowing people at least want you to
do that yeah Vegas your Vegas residency
yes
what is going on with that are you gonna
announce more date soon how is it
performing in Vegas well the first time
I was a little nervous because you know
like it's like I never did it before and
I wonder how the residency is gonna go
and it was amazing and yeah we're just
gonna have dates every month and
everything and I'm just gonna turn up
it's a big party like I'm a cool person
to party with yeah party with cardi hmm
can we talk about your abs by the way
getting that Instagram post yeah girl
what are you doing stuff stuff you look
amazing but you're always open about
your body and your post baby body how
are you feeling right now
how do I feel right now like I feel good
and then sometimes I feel like nah you
know what I'm saying like your skin is
it's like more stretched ow
yes I guess skin is more stretched ow I
just got my boobs redone did you really
yes are you in pain at all uh no no no
no
this is the axle yeah and feeling good
yes my daughter [ __ ] me up she did she
do are you still thinking about more
kids yes yeah how I feel like I love the
cloud video you and off set looked
amazing how are you guys doing we're
doing good
yeah good things repenting a lot of good
things yeah
yes what is that dynamic like when you
guys are on set it's actually it
actually was really easy what girl these
find Achilles literally yeah it was it
was actually really easy what the crazy
thing is that is like us I had such a
bad migraine that day it was so terrible
and as soon as I finish the music video
he just got me in a car and rushed me to
a hospital
wait no and you're okay though obviously
not yes yeah everything's good
health-wise you're good right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's just my craze though
yeah what do you see is the future of
the cardi B brand I see everything I
feel like I can't accomplish everything
and anything so it is like whatever that
I can't set my mind to do hmm I could do
it whatever it is seriously though you
can yeah I do want to quickly ask you
about your new at Coachella with Selena
Gomez was amazing yes what do you love
most about Selena I like what I like
about Selena is the relationship she has
like a fan base like the saloon Nader's
desalinator silly leaders yeah how to
say that her and they just always like
she's such a sweet person like how could
you not love her and it's just like they
are they're not they're telling the
truth like she is such a sweet person
like it's like oh my gosh you're so nice
you're so sweet and then they say when
when you like talk to her it's like
she's so relatable and he says I love
her like it's just like if you guys are
very similar in that way like people
just gush over you and say how what good
hearts you guys have yes which is
amazing she's really though she's really
an amazing person like you know
like every time I read things about her
in the blog site is really poor baby
because if I'm a tough [ __ ] from the
Bronx and gotta deal with the Oh faint
commotion it's just like I understand
the I dig it
some people would never understand it
because they're not in our shoes and I
get it totally I get it but I'm just so
shot at conversing you people before we
wrap up here your favorite piece in the
collection I like all of them yeah yeah
I like all of them you know you know
that I like all of them due to the fact
that is that we started off with like
200 pieces and I used to be like scratch
god speech would you wear this which
you're not involved with totally that's
amazing and what's the price point what
can you tell our viewers about this
collection I mean everybody depends just
like the last collection so you know it
could be something from $50 to $200 like
who knows but it's very affordable the
launch party in LA is gonna be epic it's
May 8th who's going to be on that get
that guest list well who is performing
you know it's all about performing yes
of course I'm gonna perform the city
girls are gonna perform
Blueface is gonna perform yg is gonna
perform it's gonna be of a really big
party and you know um I get really
nervous when it comes to parties that's
why I don't like celebrating my birthday
to energy yes it's just because I get I
get anxiety you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah totally
I'm surprised and this is like something
that we like oh my gosh what happened to
people don't come when I bring this but
the last fashionable party was such a
big success and there were so many
people that came that it's just like
this time we got a bigger venue
we're flying people out were flying like
you know like certain fans think I do
certain things that you might get fluid
out are you ready to pop some champagne
I'm just nervous I always get nervous
all the time because I just hope that
people like my collection like I just
want like everything to be successful I
don't like
no mediocre or like oh we so have or we
sold it took about five four hours to
something oh I want to serve right there
and then like I want to prove to people
like I do this can I tell you a secret
what is that everything that you touch
turns to gold so I think you're gonna be
okay amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]